you allow me i would
start by saying a few words in english
and then i will pass to spanish
president of the commission the arusula
president of the council dear charles
thank you very much for being
here with us today also high
representative peter warrell thank you
very much for being with us here today
well the facilities that we have seen
today here in the base of terre haute in
madrid
i believe
is a clear symbol of how
the european union and spain respond
this hub this spanish hub this european
hub
organized to provide support and
any help to our afghan collaborators and
refugees
represents
the values and principles of the
european union unity and solidarity
unity among
member states
under the leadership of our common
institutions the high representative the
commission the council the parliament
in order to respond
all together to common challenges
and also with unity solidarity
solidarity with those who are suffering
the most
due to this terrible
humanitarian crisis that afghanistan is
suffering today
europe responds
for good
for the good and also during the bad
times
and
dear charles dear ursula we have a
spanish saying
we say
um
estamos alasduras maduras
which clearly
embodies the position of spain in europe
we are for the
uh
i would say sweet moments
but also for the bitter ones
and uh
wherever and whenever europe needs spain
we will be there so once again thank you
very much i represent the president of
the commission and president of the
council for being with us here today i
would say a few words in spanish for the
national press
and then of course i will pass the award
to
is
repatriation
is
afghanistan
hospitals
um
thank you
dear prime minister dear pedro the
president of the commission dear ursula
first of all
i would like to
to express
our support our gratitude
to you pedro to your government to your
leadership because your decision
to take this initiative immediately
there is a signal of dignity european
dignity this palatal project the
european union is based on fundamental
principles and values unity solidarity
human rights and that's why it was so
important to demonstrate our clear
solidarity to those people in
afghanistan who helps us and the member
states to try to promote our values to
defend our interests during the last
years
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fundamentally
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much uh the prime minister
the pedro
president of the council dear charles um
i first of all also want to thank you
from the bottom of my heart di pedro
for inviting us to the reception hub
here
and i want to thank you for having taken
the initiative and i also want to thank
the high representative joseph morrell
the two of you having taken the
initiative with the respective minister
for foreign affairs and development to
coordinate the reception of incoming
afghans here who have worked for the
european union and to coordinate their
arrival here with their families
and indeed as you said pedro
you can feel it today
in the times of need
spain has shown humanity
and spain has proven a great sense
of solidarity
so spain is here an example for the
european soul at its best and i really
want to thank you
i also want to thank the personnel we've
seen today
i've seen
the red cross
the social workers that have explained
to us the facilities
the security forces we have seen
the interpreters many many volunteers
it is outstanding and to know that we
have your expertise
and your
your empathy
is invaluable for all of us and for the
people who are looking here for help
i also want to thank the member states
who are taking in our colleagues from
afghanistan and their families
this whole event we are living through
now
is a tragedy for afghanistan and it is a
severe blow for the international
community
and the more important it is that even
as the crisis engulfs
kabul that we step up as european union
at member states to expand all the
efforts of help that are necessary
we need to help
it is our moral responsibility
and not only to help the afghans
arriving here in spain but also those
who have remained in afghanistan
and here i want to emphasize that the
european union is firmly committed
to continue supporting the ngos
operating in the country
humanitarian needs are increasing with
the latest development
um if we look at the number of
internally displaced people it's the
largest number it's
3.7 million almost and 80 percent of
them are women and girls and children
and they are the most at risk so we must
help ensure
that displaced afghans can safely return
to their homes or have at least a
perspective whether they are currently
in afghanistan
or in the neighboring countries
and for that purpose
the commission is currently working on
increasing its current humanitarian aid
we had planned an envelope of 57 million
euros for 2021
but we have to increase that and we will
soon come forward with a proposal
my second point is concerning
migration above all we need to prevent
people from falling into the hands of
smugglers and human traffickers
these human traffickers put afghans who
right now try to flee the conflict
in at least as much danger
and therefore to those who cannot go
back or stay home
we have to offer alternatives
and this means first
that we must offer legal
and safe routes globally
organized by us the international
community to those who need protection
and for this to be effective we must act
together on a global level
that will be indeed one of the issues
charlene pedro that i think is central
to the g7 meeting next week
at the g7 meeting i would like to follow
up on the resettlement forum
that the commission organized in july
together with some member states with
canada the united states and the unhcr
this resettlement of vulnerable people
is of utmost importance it is our moral
duty
and in this resettlement forum we agreed
to coordinate our efforts to find much
needed solutions for refugees
in need of protection so now is the time
to put that commitment into action
and in particular we need to think about
those in imminent danger in afghanistan
such as journalists or human rights
defenders and especially women and girls
and that leads me to the point you're so
right pedro it was not in vain
there are 20 years
generations who were able to attend
schools were able to study who acquired
education
who are the ones where you never ever
can take that away anymore
the possibility to decide for your own
life and them we have to support they
are at high risk of losing all their
rights in the country so here i also
call on all states who have participated
in the afghanistan missions europeans
and others
to provide sufficient resettlement
quotas and secure pathways
so that collectively
we can accommodate those in need of
protection
the commission stands ready to look into
the necessary budgetary means to support
eu member states who will step up and
help resettle refugees
the last issue i want to touch on
concerns aid to afghanistan in this new
phase
once again humanitarian aid
has to continue
and of course the situation is very
unclear and very unpredictable we see
the taliban taking the reins of the
country
we hear of discussions to form a
government that is inclusive
we hear taliban statement that stress
that women will have their right place
in society and be able to study and work
within the framework of islam whatever
that means
but we also hear more and more reports
of people being hunted down
for their past work or their opinions
and we hear of women being turned away
when they show up at their usual
workplace
so let me be very clear on development
aid
the one billion euros
in eu funds set aside for development
aid for the next seven years
is tied to strict conditions
respect for human rights
good treatment of minorities and respect
for the rights of women and girls just
to name a few
and not a single euro can go to a regime
not a single euro of development aid
that denies women and girls their full
freedoms and rights to education and
careers
we may well hear the taliban's words
but we will measure them above all by
their deeds and their actions thank you
thank you very much
for
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
is
um
[Music]
just maybe a few words about this
important question first of course it's
always very important to coordinate it's
the eu level is it easy no it's not easy
but this time there is no doubt we have
exactly the same goals the 27 member
states we want more stability we want
more predictability and we know that we
are facing a very difficult geopolitical
situation in afghanistan but it's also
why we are so grateful to spain to have
reacted so so quickly in close
cooperation with joseph joseph burrell
in order to make sure that we are we are
able to to to take our part of
responsibility this very for the very
short term and in the next days western
member states will continue to work with
the commission and with the different
international partners in order to to
try to do our best uh in order to in
order to to to take our responsibilities
and then in the in the mid term we will
need also to coordinate and to cooperate
with the international community not
only uh among the european member states
and that's why the the meetings that we
will have in the next days and in the
next week will be very important
difficult to predict what will happen in
afghanistan but we know what we want for
the region we want more stability we
want to protect the human right it has
been set
very clearly by ursula and by and by
pedro and we will try to to continue to
promote our values and to defend our
interests
[Music]
in afghanistan
is
may i perhaps at one
point indeed i
you
the question before i did not answer
that is the question do we speak to the
taliban do we sit at the same table with
a taliban and i think it's very
important to differentiate between two
things
of course we do have operational
contacts with the taliban at the moment
being in the moment of crisis
because we need for example to discuss
in these
difficult times how we can facilitate
it for people in kabul to come towards
the airport and you know how difficult
that is in those cases of course
operational contacts are needed and it's
always good to speak if you can save
lives
but this is completely diff distinct and
separated from political talks there are
no political talks with the taliban
there is no recognition of the taliban
and
therefore
i just wanted to answer the question
[Music]
foreign
yes it is
it is of course a very difficult
situation without any question but
i witnessed from the very first minute
that the hrvp joseph burrell has
tirelessly
cared for
the personnel in the delegation
we've been in close contact all the time
we had the phone calls with jens
stoltenberg uh secretary general of nato
um in very close contact uh the hrvp is
with blinken state secretary blinken so
um this is on the political level
but
much more important is on the practical
level on the ground our head of
delegation is there with security
officers till yesterday today is the
deputy head of delegation
they are constantly at the airport
trying to facilitate for afghan staff
european union staff to come towards the
airport it is a very difficult situation
it is changing by the minute
but there is intense
work being done to
do the best of a very difficult
situation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
is
is
foreign
we commend the remarks because of course
good relations with morocco are as
important for the european union as they
are for spain so that is good and it
shows that the very close cooperation we
have together
makes it possible also in difficult
moments to manage the situation that is
important
thank you very much thank you charles
thank you
thank you all the staff
for the
really positive work that you're doing
during these
days long days
gracias
i